it is a cultural practice that has you
know like I said it predates both Islam
and Christianity so it is something that
has existed at first I believe they used
to do it on mummies in Egypt
um after they have died and then it was
done to slave women in Egypt and then it
just became a widespread practice all
over Africa Asia and the world really is
it just tradition like why why do this
thing to people one of the reasons is
religious which is absolutely berserk it
does that's not true at all and religion
has nothing to do with it a lot of
cultures do it because they're trying to
prevent either rape sexual harassment
um or you know any type of sexual abuse
others do it so that their daughter
doesn't have sex before marriage and
some do it because you know your
daughter is not going to be marryable if
she does not have the procedure done